[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat consacré ce soir à l'abattage
vous avez sûrement vu cette nouvelle
vidéo de l'association l214 filmer à
l'intérieur de l'abattoir porcin de
houdan des images choquantes que
dénoncent les défenseurs de la cause
animale
l'abattoir a de son côté écarté
l'employé auteurs de ces violences et se
défend de maltraiter ses animaux le
monde agricole le soutien au delà de ce
cas particulier ces images relance le
débat comment une telle cruauté
peut-elle avoir lieu la mise à mort des
animaux bretelles être améliorée avec
nous pour en débattre terride orléans
vous êtes membre du conseil
départemental europe ecologie les verts
des yvelines spécialisé dans les
questions agricoles et mathieu pecqueur
vous êtes directeur général adjoint de
culture viande le syndicat des
entreprises de la viande bonsoir
messieurs terride orléans
que vous inspirent ces images et bien
l214 fait un très bon travail pour
alerter en fait l'opinion publique sur
ce qui se passe dans la chaîne
alimentaire et notamment sur les
conditions animales
leur objectif est de réduire voire de
supprimer les abattent les abattoirs à
horizon on ne sait pas
nous en tant que responsables politiques
notre interrogation c'est toutes ces
mises en alerte que ce soit l 214 ou
d'autres associations sur les pratiques
agricoles au sens large doivent nous
interroger sur le système global on nous
raconte régulièrement que c'est la crise
alors soit dans la viande soit dans
l'hôtel c'est qu'on parlera des raisons
à une crise qui dure
ce n'est plus une crise c'est un système
qui est en souffrance et qu'il faudra
revoir mathieu pecqueur sans pointer du
doigt une profession toute personne
visualisant ces vidéos
quand même se dit mais comment peut-on
toutes ces vidéos et les actes de
maltraitance qu'elle démontre sont
choquants et elles ont choqué les les
abattoirs et or premier lieu les
salariés qui travaillent dans les
entreprises de la viande parce qu'elles
savent très bien que c'est pas de la
manière dont elles exercent leur métier
savent parfaitement que il ya énormément
de réglementation qui ont été mises en
place sur laquelle de la protection
animale et tout en condamnant clairement
les actes de maltraitance qu'on voit sur
ces vidéos on se dit aussi que ces
vidéos ou un objectif qui est de
quelque part condamné la consommation de
viande et l'élevage et que faire croire
que ces vidéos sont généralisées à
l'ensemble des abattoirs c'est faux et
c'est quelque part un peu malhonnête
intellectuellement quand on sait qu'il
ya énormément de contraintes qui pèsent
aujourd'hui sur les entreprises de
viande en termes de protection animale
et c'est pour ça que vous êtes là ce
soir pour rappeler ses contraintes
rappeler toutes les réglementations
rappelé toute la formation qu'on a pu
mettre en place et rappelé la manière
dont nos salariés travaillent et toutes
les bonnes pratiques qui prouvent qu'ils
peuvent mettre en place c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu énormément de choses et le progrès
qui ont été faits mais vous au sein de
votre formation quand vous entendez
parler de ces images quand vous les
voyez quand elles viennent jusqu'à vous
vous vous dites quoi vous dit vous savez
ce qui peut se produire et ce qui peut
se produire on détecte parce qu'on a des
expériences chez nous les les actes de
maltraitance qu'on voit sur ces vidéos
est clairement utilisé une pile
électrique sur un animal pour le faire
avancer
c'est pas permis dans nos guides de
bonnes pratiques pour
la protection animale l'on n'avait vu
dans une vidéo précédente
un salarié qui prend un mouton et il
jette contre une barrière c'est
clairement un acte de maltraitance donc
tout ça on le voit ce qu'on dit nous
c'est qu'il y à des formations pour ses
salariés
il y à des responsables de la protection
animale qui les encadre et il ya des
vétérinaires de l'état qui sont présents
dans nos entreprises donc tout est mis
en place pour que ça n'arrive pas il
faut que tout le monde ait bien
conscience que ce qu'on voit sur cette
vidéo c'est pas du tout généralisée
terrible réactivation en fait c'est un
peu le contrepoids de ce qui se fait
depuis des années l'industrie
alimentaire tente de nous faire croire
que la viande qui se trouvent dans les
assiettes est complètement déconnecté
d'un être vivant aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
il ya beaucoup de gens qui pensent que
les poissons s'est déclaré et que
l'estac s'est pas des des animaux
vivants au départ et en fait ça doit
nous interroger sur le système est notre
rapport à la respect de la vie en fonte
vraiment alors justement depuis 2013 il
y à un responsable bien être animal dans
les abattoirs on prend quand même un bon
chemin mais tout dépend parce que quand
on regarde un peu toutes les analyses et
par rapport notamment aux dérèglements
climatiques
il va nous falloir consommer beaucoup
moins de viande
c'est une nécessité en 2050 on aura 30%
on verra 30 % de population
supplémentaire on a en moyenne une
personne mange en moyenne 500 grammes à
un kilo et demi en fait de viande par
semaine et je vais intervenir sur ce
point là parce qu'il va falloir il va
falloir lever c'est de toute façon
l'élevage dans toute sa globalité
représente 20 % des gaz des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre une consommation
d'eau qui est gigantesque et là on parle
spécifiquement des abattoirs et ces
images sont très choquantes les
conditions en aux abattoirs précisément
et
la législation a progressé la
législation ne remplacera pas les
pratiques et l'abattoir ce n'est qu'une
aide à retrouver sur ce quoi l'élevage
même en soin des animaux et parfois
choquant enfin ce que l'on fait subir
aux veaux par exemple pour qu'ils aient
une vente d'une viande blanche on les
retire alors à leur mère deux trois
jours après la naissance
pour certains c'est de trois jours dans
l'intensif et surtout on les 46 ans
certains aliments pour que la viande
soit blanche parce que dans le concept
de culture elle il faut que le veau la
viande du veau sauce blanche
les réponses ont été on peut se
retrouver seul sur la question de la
protection animale
c'est avant tout la formation avant tout
l'homme qui va permettre que les animaux
souffrent pas quand ils sont à
l'abattoir je pense que les choses sont
claires c'est en formant nos salariés
c'est en leur inculquant les bonnes
pratiques et la manière dont les animaux
réagissent que on va pouvoir faire que
les animaux ne souffre pas quand on les
cantons les passes quand on est pas sur
la chaîne d'abattage
là où je me retrouve moins dans vos
propos c'est non en france on ne
consomme pas trop dur en france les
recommandations nous disent qu'il faut
en consommer 500 grammes on est en
moyenne à 3 170 grammes par semaine
donc il faut entre en scène c'est de
toute façon on ne consomme pas trop de
viande et même sur le sujet
environnemental
on peut nous dire qu'il faut baisser
pour favoriser la consommation de
produits végétaux elles toutes les
études il y en a encore une qui a été
faite récemment par l'inra montrent que
si on se mettait à consommer que des
produits végétaux les surfaces agricoles
n'y suffirait pas tout simplement parce
que pour fournir autant de protéines et
autant de faire que la viande évincé pas
100 g de viande contre 100 grammes de
produits végétaux c'est 100 g de viande
contre eux 300 400 500 g de lentilles à
partir de là les produits végétaux ne
remplace pas la viande donc il faut que
la viande se produisent dans les
meilleures conditions possibles en
élevage dans leur transport et
en abattage jusqu'à la transformation
puisque on peut parler aussi de la
sécurité sanitaire derrière mais on peut
aujourd'hui consommer de la viande qui a
été élevé de manière extrêmement saine
et respectueuse de l'animal qui a été
abattu dans des meilleures conditions
possibles en rendant l'animal
inconscient avant avant sa saignée en
sahara en vérifiant qu'il est bien
conscient que je disais il ya des
processus très centré sur ces sur ses
méthodes d' étourdissements il ya eu
aussi des dysfonctionnements voilà l214
a révélé des abattoirs tuer des animaux
qui était encore conscient c'est c'est
un résultat logique de la course à la
productivité
il y à une docu depuis l'après guerre on
nous dit il faut produire de plus en
plus de plus en plus de plus en plus
d'ailleurs il y a même des éleveurs qui
sont sortis de ce système de production
lorsque des chaînes d'abattage sont
dimensionnés pour un certain nombre d'
animal et que mon pic de production
enfin ces mots sont terribles d'ailleurs
on empile d'abattage il est logique que
par exemple les employés soient très
fatigué parce que les conditions de
travail de ses employés sont très dures
souvent sous-effectif qu'on a on a un
taux par exemple d'accidents du travail
dans cette profession qui est très
nettement au dessus des autres
professions on a à peu près de 80 %
d'après les études de gens qui
travaillent dans ces abattoirs qui
déclarent des maladies professionnelles
les conditions sont très durs mais on
est inquiet car on est là par hasard sur
un métier et sur un métier industriel où
on est sur des métiers qui peuvent qui
peuvent être physiques et sa maintenance
allongé depuis de puissance il cherche
des producteurs c'est dans l'air du
temps là où il faut pas qu'on soit non
plus
une forme de d'angélisme c'est les
circuits courts les circuits avec les
petits abattoirs ne garantissent pas
mieux la protection animale que les
groupes aujourd'hui l'agrément sanitaire
qu'on reçoit il est fait donc par l'état
par les services vétérinaires pour un
certain nombre d'animaux à l'heure et
effectivement on voit nous dans nos
entreprises qu'une chaîne d'abattage qui
est extrêmement bien conçu une chaîne
d'abattage qui occupe 15 ou 20 personnes
peut avoir une cadence très rapide mais
parce que chacun fait une tâche
relativement simple alors qu'une chaîne
d'abattage dans un plus petites
entreprises qui n'a que deux ou trois
personnes ne peut pas tourner aussi
vitaux qu'on n'est pas sur une logique
de la cadence fait qu'on maltraite
l'animal on est sur annecy second
constat dans certains abattoirs la
cadence montre est l'animal en
l'occurrence l'ensemble les vidéos qu'on
pu être diffusées étaient plutôt dans
des entreprises qui étaient de petite
taille et avec des cas rapportés ou
danser à peu près une centaine
d'employés votre petit abattoir en fait
c'est manqué quel est votre solution
parce que les premières vidéos il ya une
première vidéo en 2009 je crois fin
juillet et ça arrive encore aujourd'hui
quelles solutions
aujourd'hui ce qu'on dit nous c'est que
la réglementation est encore une
réglementation relativement neuve c'est
un règlement européen qui date de 2009
qui est entrée en vigueur en 2013
on a formé six mille personnes pour
vérifier qu'elles ont bien toutes les
compétences en termes de protection
animale toutes nos salariés qui sont au
contact des animaux ont été formés sur
la question de la protection animale et
à côté d'elle on a formé ce qu'on
appelle des responsables protection
animale qui vérifie que les process sont
bien sont bien appliquées donc cette
formation elle doit encore aller plus
loin c'est un métier qui est neuf donc
il faut qu'il trouve toute sa place dans
l'entreprise et de la même manière que
les responsables qualité sur les
questions sanitaires ont mis du temps à
s'installer
les responsables de protection animale
il faut qu'ils trouvent toute leur place
au niveau de culture vie en ont créé un
réseau pour qu'ils se parlent entre eux
qu'ils échangent des bonnes pratiques et
qu'ils puissent quelque part leur faut
progresser en commun ça nous semble être
la bonne voie marc santerre
c'est ce qui est inquiétant en fait dans
ce genre de propos effectivement il faut
améliorer la réglementation
mais si on interroge pas le système
d'ailleurs on le voit dans le propos de
monsieur pecqueur on parle de viande on
ne parle pas d'animaux en fait on est
dans la culture viande
ce sont des animaux vivants mon arrière
grand père était paysan dans une ferme
il y avait une sorte de respect de la
vie de la vie de l'animal dans son
élevage au sérieux aussi
nous allons y sont extrêmement
respectueux de la vie de l'année
sûrement ce payement respectueuse seppi
s'est alors sable d'ailleurs
parfaitement je ne parle pas des gens là
je parle du système en fait on est dans
un système industriel aux systèmes
industriels
alors ça c'est clair on va pas s'arrêter
du jour au lendemain donc il faut
trouver des solutions d'accompagnement
dès lors que l'on court à la
surproduction et je pense que nous
sommes dans un système de surproduction
et d'ailleurs on le voit les marchés
baissent de plus en plus l'idée marché
et réduire la production
il faudrait interroger tout le système
dans sa globalité est-ce que
il est raisonnable par exemple de faire
des fermes gigantesque enfin des fermes
des usines à viande ou on maltraite les
animaux dès leur naissance pour au final
nourrir des gens à moindre coût avec des
qualités alimentaires très faible on est
en recherche de qualité mais de qualité
de respect de la vie de qualité de
respect des consommateurs des paysans
etc
pour le coup et c'est aussi des vertus
sur ce point là on a quand même un
système d'élevage et qui est encore
extrêmement familial avec des petites
fermes à lens pas parce qu'on a fait un
très gros débat sur la ferme des
millevaches et des fermes des
millevaches en allemagne balkans regard
des antennes ou des dizaines et les
vaches des cochons en bretagne c'est
terrible on est sur une concentration et
une surproduction pourtant on reste sur
des petites exploitations à l'échelle
européenne on reste sur des petites
exploitations en porc comme boeuf à
l'échelle européenne qui sont gérés par
des familles et des éleveurs qui sont
globalement respectueux de leurs animaux
et c'est vrai qu'on est sur un modèle
qui en france reste très qualitatif on a
une traçabilité comme on en a nulle part
ailleurs et on a en termes de protection
animale pour revenir sur ce sujet là un
contrôle qui est permanent par l'état
des gens qui sont formés et clairement
voilà les bonnes pratiques elles sont là
qu'on puisse s'améliorer je l'entends
mais qu'on ferme prendre mon propos prix
initial les mauvaises pratiques qu'on a
vu sur certain nombre de vidéos sont
loin d'être généralisée est clairement
dans le manger de la viande qui a été
bien a battu narbonne positionner bien
un dernier mot sera plus rapidement les
conditions des animaux en fait notre
rapport avec les animaux est un rapport
de prédateur même pire que c'est un
rapport de consommateurs qui ne respecte
pas la vie animale quand on coupe la
queue des cochons et quand on les
cantons leur couple est dedans pour
qu'ils ne s'entretuent pas entre eux
dans des bandes éclos dans des enclos
très très restreint il ya un problème et
je voudrais juste finir par une phrase
de gandhi qui est très importante à
notre sens c'est une civilisation qui ne
respecte pas la vie court à sa perte et
on a ce travail aussi culturelle à faire
merci ce sera le dernier mot vous avez
répondu tout à l'heure en parlant
justement de ces améliorations qui
viendront
mettre du temps à s'installer merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau débat merci très bonne soirée
[Musique]